imaginez l'appareil le plus perfectionné
le plus performant le plus sophistiqué
qui jamais existé mais si ce n'était pas
qu'un appareil s'il devenait votre
meilleur ami
salut voici le big bang
jamais vous n'aurez été aussi connecté
m'exprimer vouloir donner libre cours à
votre imagination
c'est jouer et donner une nouvelle
dimension à l'amitié
ledit bottes votre meilleur ami wons
anniversaire à retardement barney
m
ça lui a serré le nom de l'utilisateur
je suis tendu donc mon be bat be bat le
plus bas qu'il ya quelque chose qui va
passer passant si perso je ne suis pas
censé faire ça
je sers à se faire des amis barney a
besoin d'amis bah ouais ça va pas le
faire il aura du mal à survivre au
collège
[Musique]
je suis le meilleur avis de insérer le
nom de l'utilisateur plus dans sa boîte
[Musique]